you know i remember
one of the first times i ever even
performed i was
you know a child or something i think i
was a child or i was just a small adult
that was just lying about how old he was
but i was or you know just a middle-aged
child or something i don't know probably
about nine
and if we were bad which we were
my mother would make us perform do a
performance
so we could come downstairs and watch
rescue 911
on television because that was my show
man
that was my thing that was my jam i love
to call 9-1-1
and some of you guys know that about me
and some of you don't
i'll call them matches i'll text them
you know i texted them from the poirier
holloway fight
i said they got some damn ruffians out
here beating the [ __ ] out of each other
you know and they said where are you i
said i'm at the
ufc whatever it was 214 baby where are
you guys dude gang [ __ ] bring the fire
department
but you can text 9-1-1 now but when i
was young i would call them i'd call
them for anything
you know i'd call them if we'd if we
couldn't pay the bills i'd call them
hey uh yep uh
saint tammany parish police and fire how
may i help you
is this an emergency yep um
we can't pay the water
mom can't pay it so she
you know she told her boss off and she
got fired so
um sorry um you i'm gonna have to
uh keep the line free for actual
emergencies
but at least i'll let them know some of
you gotta let the city know what you're
thinking
you gotta at least let them know what
you're dealing with you know
but um but anyway i remember
you know that we my mom would make us we
had she didn't make us but we would come
down and perform
you know we would put paint or something
on our bodies or put a sheet on top of
us
and write china on it maybe and do you
know get in a a
like a line and put a couple sheet on us
and make a dragon
we'd come down and you know you know my
brother would beat a little uh
you know he'd have him beat a
what is it called uh he would beat like
a tambourine with a spoon
or you know we had a
we had a this man my mom dated used to
do fake accidents to get money
and so we had a remember like a metal
neck brace that he left over one time
and so
sometimes my brother would put that on
and get thimbles like you know metal
little thimbles from
sewers sewers kits and he would put him
on his
fingers and so we'd all come down and he
would play kind of
chinese music on his you know
[Music]
just
just you know playing that that metal
neck brace
and uh and the rest of us would just be
in a damn
sheet we'd written china on the side of
it and cut a couple eye holes out the
front
and wrote dragon on the front and we
would do a show put on a show for mom
and if she liked the show well enough
then we were allowed to
sit there by the television and watch
rescue 9-1-1
or so you know a couple other programs
unsolved mysteries rescue 9-1-1
america's most wanted i mean we like to
watch [ __ ] that was very fear-based
and we would sit dude we were killing we
would sit literally
two inches from the television screen
i mean our television was as big as two
iphone
nines i mean that [ __ ] was
as big as two off like a double wide
iphone 9
and we would sit there two inches from
it
and just let it all just let the devil
just go straight into our eyes
and that was you know that was but that
was some of the first times we performed
that i would perform i remember as a
child was coming down
and doing that and performing for mom
so that we could watch rescue 9-1-1 good
evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
ah